in the danesque region of Ukraine a
russian-appointed election official
tours a polling station this is one of
four regions where people are voting to
join the Russian Federation
we Grant the right to vote to all
citizens of the Donetsk People's
Republic as well as abroad
in a nearby park people under the
watchful eye of the Russian State say
they welcome the referendum
Russia has always been our motherland
without it we have no one left Ukraine
abandoned us long ago
foreign there are no International
election monitors only those invited by
Russia media have been tightly
controlled many Western analysts say
it's nothing more than an exercise by
the Kremlin to shape how people think
about Russian occupied parts of Ukraine
this is no referendum this is no
expression of will but at the same time
they want to say face meaning getting
observers meaning filming stories of
work when voting at polling stations the
protocols being written and so on this
is kind of an imitational democracy
model where pictures are important
in some areas Russian installed
officials said they would be going door
to door with police to invite residents
to vote critics say it's clear
intimidation under international law it
is illegal to hold referendums during
conflict and where people are under
threat most countries as well as
International bodies such as the
European Union and United Nations have
said they won't recognize the results
the head of Ukraine's Election
Commission has told us the vote violates
the Constitution
there are no legal mechanics in the
Ukrainian Constitution to give up
territories this is completely
unconstitutional under martial law that
we live under now it is prohibited by
Ukrainian laws to organize any
referendum on our lands
in 2014 Russia held a referendum in
Crimea in which it alleged 96 percent to
the people voted to join the Federation
five days later
the annexation of Crimea was signed into
law it now appears that same process is
happening again but in a much larger
area in the middle of a war
and with more at stake for both Ukraine
and Russia
Gabriel osondo Al Jazeera Kiev